Rangi children like Zora have seen
things no child should see she survived
the massacre at Dole atole a village
where hundreds were slaughtered shot
burned alive the dead include her mother
father brothers they were shooting at us
and setting fire to our houses so we ran
to the river we were lying down on a
riverbank when they started shooting
again and they killed everyone me and my
brother managed to escape I saw my
sister's body
I saw people being hacked to death by
men wearing khaki uniforms szura shows
me where she was shot in the thigh as
she fled now orphaned at 12 and left
alone to care for her 10 year old
brother
Maiasaura what she thought
she has no words good to belong refugee
camp is now home to over 600,000
reindeer who have fled slaughter in
Myanmar they're starving and they're
sick
one in four is suffering from
life-threatening malnutrition thin limbs
and distended stomach filled with worms
are commonly cholera and dysentery lurk
in the fecal infested water but the
challenge facing these overwhelmed
medics is not limited to the children's
physical health everybody is going to
have the most traumatic stress disorder
because they left everything what they
had and number two they said they saw
many of their relatives dying in front
of them and they were butchered I'd say
butchered this is the only time you'll
see happy rehang here children
inside a special child-friendly space
distraction from their wretched lives
there seem to be a bit and that we pick
up and that needs to be dealt with
careful with care because the children
but there's little love for the world's
most persecuted people because
Bangladesh is notorious sex trade is
already exploiting the raingear crisis
we're on one of the main roads leading
out of the refugee camp and this is a
police checkpoint they're here to stop
the Rangers from leaving but human
traffickers are ruthless people they
know how to prey on the weak and
desperate and there are plenty of those
here Qasim is a human trafficker and
belongs to a gang of pimps targeting
women and young girls inside could
belong
we get about five pounds for each girl
we bring to the city we come with 1520
girls and then handle move some do it
because they're poor others are widows
they work to survive the government
handouts aren't enough to live on they
need medicine to their kids so they
become prostitutes other girls do it
because their parents can't afford a
dowry to marry them off others do sex
work to support elderly parents there
are more and more Roe hinga coming to
the camps they've lost everything
they're desperate so the number of pimps
and the refugee camps has grown and it's
big business now you can even find
people sleeping rough on the streets
with no shelter and they have unmarried
girls with them so my business is
driving this is the new rain gear
generation traumatized sick and
vulnerable
children doomed to spend the rest of
their lives inside the refugee camp
because when the reindeer cried for help
the world ignored their plight until it
was too late
Ashish Joshi Sky News and adesh